my sense is that in men many forms of
this stimulus are like pushing a string
and so these banks that took all of
these risks and therefore find
themselves and desperately needing
liquidity you can push the liquidity
into a bank but you cannot push the
liquidity out of the bank it can only be
pulled from the other side and in a
similar way you can cut taxes and push
that liquidity into consumers banking
accounts but you can't pull it out the
other side and one of the dangers in a
recession is that the instinct of
individuals and the instinct of banks is
to hunker down and preserve their own
financial viability not too aggressively
spend the money or loan the money and so
even though in in normal situations you
know like Ronald Reagan showed us that a
big tax cut really could stimulate a
decade of economic growth in this kind
of a risky situation I suspect that
putting liquidity into banks and putting
liquidity into people's bank accounts
through tax cuts the liquidity is likely
to stay there and not get pulled out the
other side and generate employment and
so the kinds of things that are part of
the stimulus package where the
government actually goes to the other
side and uses the money to create
employment so the rebuilding of the
infrastructure and things like that is
really a great idea because it's it's
there is a direct causal link between
you spending and people going to work
and then they're going to work their
ability to consume that's where I would
focus the stimulus money I think the
other stuff you may want to do it just
because you have to prop up
the banks but you should not do it in
the anticipation that it will solve the
recession's troubles